روح الميلاد تجمعنا هي رساله الميلاد من
بيت لحم الى العالم رساله اكدها غبطه
باتريارك اللاتيني في القدس بيير باتيستا
بيسابالا في قداس منتصف الليل من كنيسه
المهد بحضور الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
ولفيفه من رجال الدين وشخصيات دبلوماسيه
ومجتماعيه فلسطينيه
مره جديده اراده الخير بين كل الناس وان
يقوي ثقتنا بكل انسان وان يؤيد عملنا في
سبيل السلام والرحمه والعدل في الارض
المقدسه وفي العالم باحات الكنيسه من
الخارج شهدت رغم بروده الطقس جانبا من
الاحتفال بالعيد وزياره المحتلين لشجره
الميلاد التي انارت المكانه بذنتها
افراح الميلادي بتفاصيلها باديه في المشهد
هنا في بيت لحم لكنها تمثل في الوقت ذاته
حاله من الصمود والتحدي امام ما يتعرض له
الفلسطينيون من معاناه بفعل استمرار
الاحتلال وانتهاكاته اليوميه
فلم يستلم البطريرك نفسه كما في كل عام من
تداعيات الاحتلال ووجوده على الارض
الفلسطينيه فقد اجتاز موكبه الرسميه تحت
انظار جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي احدى
بوابات الجدار الفاصل بين مدينه القدس
المحتله وبيت لحم
ورغم هذه المنقصات فان عشرات من الفرق
الكشفيه التي توشحت صدور بعض عازفيها
بصوره الزميله الشهيده شيرين ابو عاقله
تخليدا لروحها في هذا اليوم تقدم تلك
الفرق موكب الباطيات حتى وصل الى ساحه
الكنيسه واصبح حشود المحتفلين
المسيحيه والاسلام مع بعض ومن كل دول
العالم بيجوا بعيدوا هون لانه هون ولد
المسيح
ومن ابرز ما يميز احتفالات هذا العام وفقا
للمؤسسات الرسميه انها جاءت في ظل انتعاش
السياحه في المدينه بعد عامين اعجفين بسبب
رائحه كورونا وقيود الاحتلال المستمره
جانب الاسرائيلي بيعطي صوره غير مشركه عن
الشعب الفلسطيني عبوف الشايع يعملوا له
غسيل دماغ انه الفلسطينيين الارهابيين
وديروا بالكم بهذا المناطق مما يستدعي انه
في مدينه بيت لحم وفنادق بيت لحم لكن
اجمالا الوضع جيد مقارنه بالسنين الكورنه
وفي هذه الاجواء منعت سلطات الاحتلال نحو
200 من المسيحيين قطاع غزه من الوصول الى
بيت لحم للاحتفال بعيد الميلاد سمير ابو
شمالي الجزيره بيت لحم فلسطين